[Music]
strive must see you ah I want to first
start off by saying that you have easily
been one of the most instrumental
leaders in shaping my journey and you've
even been responsible for my journey
here to Stanford Business School so it's
truly an honor to be here today and I
think I speak for many of the people
here in this audience that it's truly an
honor so I'd like to start with one of
the most compelling pieces of advice
I've heard from any business leader
you've mentioned that the three most
important skills in business are to read
count and sell take us back to the early
days of your career and how you
cultivated these skills and use them to
become a successful entrepreneur well
first of all it's it's a it's indeed a
great privilege and honor to be here
thank you for inviting me in particular
our my colleague and dear friend the
chairman of Stanford Jeff Raikes thank
you Jeff
Jeff and I work on the Alliance for a
green revolution in Africa and he
invited us here to hold our board
meeting here so I've got a number of my
colleagues from the board and Judith
Rodin I see they're Josette and Lina
thank you so much for joining us this
today well you gonna be able to read you
gotta be able to count and you gotta be
able to sell in reality that's what we
as entrepreneurs do when I was a little
boy my mother she came up with this idea
that I should earn my own pocket money
so she bought me a box of chewing gum
and I started selling them to my school
in my school but I got lost on the way
back home because i reconned read that
well cuz that's only little
so I quickly learned that you gotta be
able to sell I could count but I
couldn't read before that's probably why
I did maths and engineering so let's
talk a little bit more about
entrepreneurship it's easy for a lot of
us to think of entrepreneurship from a
more current context it's such a hot
topic and respected career path here
with thousands of tech startups emerging
each year but let's go back to Zimbabwe
in the early 90s when you first had the
vision for
econet what gave you the courage to take
on such a daring and uncommon career
path well by the by the time I decided
to set up Econet in 1993 I had been in
business for about six or seven years so
I had a well-established business
because I started in 1986 so it's
actually 25 and the so I had built up a
fairly successful construction business
I mean I'm an engineer and in
telecommunications so the whole mobile
revolution was something I had been
tracking since school actually you know
when I was at university we already knew
what was going on like most engineers do
it at school you know you if you want to
know what's going on in artificial
intelligence talk to the guys at
Stanford they'll tell you what's gonna
happen in ten years so we knew this is
this was gonna happen and it's going to
be big but 1993 was particularly
important in in my tracking because
that's when they were introducing the
digital standard which we call GSM and I
immediately knew this is the time to get
in and I thought it was gonna be a
fairly simple thing you know you I went
to my former employers and I said hey
guys this thing's gonna happen
I'd like to do a joint venture with you
and I she used to have a letter I think
someone from the intelligence stole it
but I just have a letter which used to
be on my wall written by the head of the
telephone company back to me to say you
know this is a fad it's going to
disappear we have more important things
to do here so don't bother us so I went
back and I said okay since you don't
want to be bothered let me do it they
said no you can't do that because then
you would violate our monopoly I said so
how can you have a monopoly in something
you don't do so I did the smartest thing
which was hire a lawyer right I went to
a lawyer I said you know do they really
have a monopoly he says no they don't
but if you really want to take them on
there's easier thing to do just steal a
tank and go pocket before in front of
the president's office that's it
much quicker because because that's how
he's gonna react I think somebody did it
to him about three weeks ago
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so anyway I took them to court and I
hired a lawyer from New York and an
amazing American lawyer called Judith
O'Neil and she was a specialist in
telecommunications law but she couldn't
practice in our jurisdiction and she
read the law and she said to me you know
you've got a point I'll help you with
this so she actually used to come to her
RA and advise my legal team on on the on
this battle and it took us five years
Wow
so at the time
you are trying to bring in a service
when 75% of Africans had not heard a
telephone ringing so you were trying to
solve a problem that Africans did not
yet know they had how did you gain the
boldness and the conviction to take on
such a problem at the time you know when
I worked as a telephone engineer you
know imagine we used to take out adverts
the government used a saying to people
you talk too much on the phone dad used
to say don't jabber jabber so much to
the customers I mean together when you
work for the telephone company in any
African country one of the great you
know whenever you walk down the street
people would come up to you and say you
know can you help me get a telephone
line it was just it was a badge of honor
and a lot of my friends made money out
of it was called corruption yeah but it
was it could take officially 14 years to
get a telephone in most African
countries our teledensity was point zero
seven percent so it was literally
impossible for anyone to have a
telephone line and and when we went to
the Constitutional Court
we took this thing through the lower
courts and of course be honest by the
time we got the constitutional court
I was public enemy number one I mean it
wasn't funny I used to get arrested so
but when we finally get to the
Constitutional Court we had to get
evidence for our court to even consider
it's not very different from your own
Supreme Court and we would we were to
face a nine-member bench
the matter had was no longer about the
monopoly it we had taken it as a natural
freedom of expression and so we said
look 75 percent of the people of this
country have never heard a telephone
ringing that was the headline of and
that captured headlines across the
entire African continent seventy-five
percent of our people have never heard a
telephone ringing and and people were
calling in so where did you get this
statistic from and I showed them where
we got it we had to gather this research
which is very important as an
entrepreneur you've got to get your data
so the you know the quote pull down the
monopoly and for me it was really we
were just trying to respond to a need
the the revolution for me in
telecommunications in Africa when we
look back now that is just over 20 years
ago 75 percent of the African people
have a telephone now not just ring but
their own one because our teledensity
now is 75 percent continentally some
countries like Botswana well you know
their hundred and twenty percent one
hundred and thirty percent I don't know
how they do that's that in Nigeria I
know how they do it because it's the
robes you see so they have one phone
here
but it's it's it's a remarkable
revolution for for our industry it seems
like every step of the way building
trustworthy partnerships were
fundamental to your success whether it
was gaining the trust of agents who
enable mobile money to work or the trust
of the hundreds of young people who
first spread the message of eco nuts
during the early days how did you get
people to trust you you know I think the
key is by not being transactional in
relationships and in it goes broader
than just your relationship with
customers getting people to accept
mobile money rather than mobile phones
what's the most counterintuitive thing
we ever had to do because you're talking
to people who who don't have money where
very little money and they also had no
bank accounts so we had to persuade them
that they could give us their money in
the case of Zimbabwe they had faced
500,000 percent
hyperinflation they knew if you put
money in the bank the next day you
didn't have it and we had a launch
mobile money during that time so I used
to say to my people I said when we're
discussing how do you take mobile money
across how do we get people to accept it
it's just like trying to get people to
drink how did they do that coca-cola a
black drink in a bottle but they did it
right to build this incredible company
coca-cola I mean that must have been the
most difficult thing to get somebody to
that black stuff you drink
well we got people to open bank accounts
millions of them and one of the ways we
used to do it which you familiar many of
you with what we call my tattoos right
in Africa the little comm bees so we
went to the universities and we hired
the university students and we wanted
them to ride on my tattoos so they ride
two by two in my tattoos but you know
how noisy and lively African buses are
right we talk to each other so get onto
the bus and you start they're supposed
to strike a conversation about mobile
money
I'm sending money to my cousin on the
other side of town the whole bus stops
and they talk they get off the next bus
stop they get onto the next one and they
had to do this and we had a calculation
that said we needed them to talk to one
and a half million people to get to our
tipping point there's no marketing that
was it those guys on the buses talking
and getting lost the next one and people
did realize the same guys
coming on the bus and having an argument
about and and we also said street a
comedy where they will someone who say
you stolen my money and they start a
mock fight in the middle of a Township
and people will always gather and
there's a fight right so they then
explain that actually you can't steal my
money because it's in my phone and and
I've got people to go out and register
and so these are just techniques that
are people work on amazing here at the
Stanford Business School we we celebrate
failure we even go as far as to say it's
necessary for growth and success and to
look at a leader such as yourself it can
be extremely tempting to view you as
absent of failure given that
entrepreneurship one of the hardest
parts is managing your own psychology
can you talk to us about how you've
navigated failure and self-doubt well I
wouldn't stand say I've ever celebrated
failure I've run into it now and again
say that ok probably the most
spectacular was my entry into Nigeria
now that was pretty spectacular you know
we went in just after the end of
military rule in Nigeria this would be I
guess 99 2000 and because one in five
black people in the world is a Nigerian
this is some market and we were trying
to get in and we went in and of course
we had to build a consortium and Nigeria
was particularly difficult today you've
got billions of dollars going into
Nigeria but if you look back in 2000
2001
there's no mobile industry in Niger
and no one was putting money into
Nigeria
I remember going around the banks in
South Africa and investors and the city
you mad you want to go to Nigeria so we
have to be in Niger if you're gonna be
in business in Africa you have to be in
Nigeria period so we went in and we
built a consortium of Nigerian
high-net-worth businesses and business
leaders and so to bid for a license and
the government had set up an auction
system and they became the most
expensive even to this day licenses ever
issued in sub-sahara south of us are you
know in Tunisia something paid more for
it but we paid in 2001 two hundred and
eighty five million dollars for a
license and a year into the business
one of my partner's walked in and put a
bill on the table for one of the state
governors and said you know you got to
pay us each four million dollars or we
throw you out of the country so I got
thrown out of the country and and lost
you know pretty much got kicked out of
that investment it took me ten years of
international arbitration to to win back
our investment that we had lost and
along the way I I had that governor
jailed spent 13 years in Britain British
prison after making a mistake of going
to Dubai gore picked up by Interpol I
mean it's known fact that I he I was
witness against him for corruption so
you know there was bittersweet very
difficult time for us but there were a
lot of entrepreneurial lessons
and after five years we went back into
Nigeria and the fastest-growing parts of
our businesses are in Nigeria today so
we learnt a lot that was really really
difficult and there were no celebrations
except when I got the arbitral award
which is the biggest in African history
so there was a nice end to it you've
been thought out by many leaders such as
Barack Obama but who do you look to for
inspiration
are there any up-and-coming young
leaders on the continent that inspire
you about the future of Africa
absolutely you know when I started that
Facebook page my daughter I didn't know
that my daughter was at college in the
US was sharing things I was sending her
with her friends so she started saying
to me but you know my friends think you
should talk about this that's what
friends said well you know we share
everything so we should we then got to
start working on this Facebook page and
the most interesting part for me is
reading the comments I just get
absolutely inspired by the comments of
young Africans from virtually every
corner of the continent who are running
businesses in extraordinary situations
that even I couldn't have imagined and
they're making a success of it so I
really get inspired by what our young
entrepreneurs are doing and I am in
constant conversations with them on
Facebook
I haven't know some of them you know I
go into meetings I say where's Austin
and stuff like this and they come
because they're doing amazing things and
but surely you got people like Giuliana
Rotich the young Kenyan woman who built
a Shahidi
we got Fred Fred is Fred here too
fred's Wanaka the African Leadership
Academy many of you know fred is an
alumni of Stanford I mean these are the
guys who are going to totally transform
our continent and the world to be honest
so but you know it's it's not so much
and it's a great privilege of course
when you can have a conversation with
people I President Obama who I knew
before he was president and I always
remind him that know I'm eight months
older it's just - we know this helps you
to get a stability and then it's such a
great success but in Africa Damaris I'm
senior brother so no but we are it
really it's it's people I work with over
the years people like dr. Judith Rodin
she's here she's the former president of
the Rockefeller Foundation she's been an
amazing mentor to me over the last ten
years particularly an understanding
philanthropy because many of us as
entrepreneurs when we set out to go into
philanthropy we we actually don't know
how it works
and you need to learn to be talking to
people like dr. Rodin to understand so
it's a lot of people that I work with
over a very very long time that I turn
to when I face challenges
shifting to philanthropy a bit in
addition to your success as an
entrepreneur you've funded the education
of over 40,000 children across in Bob
way and Africa how must it feel to have
come so far from humble beginnings and
what has motivated you to give back in
such an extraordinary way
well well first of all I'm really
excited this week because we just got an
announcement that we got our the Rhodes
of our program this year and we got one
last year and we I think that's our
third or fourth now so and it began like
a lot of things I don't think we my wife
and I sat down and said you know let's
give back because to be honest with you
we started when we didn't have any money
so there's almost nothing to give back
if you if you think of it that way there
was a crisis in Africa at the time which
was hiv/aids people were dying on a
scale you cannot imagine if in my small
business I was burying members of my my
workforce every week you know we
actually saw we're all gonna die that's
how it felt living in Africa in 1990-91
because of the HIV crisis and what made
the crisis so difficult were these
children what would we do with the
children I knew what happens when
children don't go to school we had
Liberia to tell us about that child
soldiers all sorts of challenges you
could rip apart a country if these kids
did not go to school so for us it was
responding to that and we came up with
this model which my wife then said she
was gonna run full time it was basically
if if we can find a relative to the
child rather than try to
institutionalize any children
let's find their relatives and tell
their relatives we will meet the
economic side we'll pay for school fees
we'll give you some food we'll pay will
help with clothing and so forth so it
began as a little program really around
our own employees
and we probably had 50 when my wife kind
of began to do it on a full-time basis
and she'd come from work and she would
just really just make sure these kids
were looked after and one day you know
it just walked in and said actually you
know you know they're 5000 that we now
help and we've extended beyond the
company because people keep bringing
these kids to us so we built it from
there and as of this year twenty odd
years into it we've assisted 250,000
that went through our system of
education we began to X wherever we went
the first thing we told our management
teams if we went to Botswana or Zambia
any country you've got to set up the
program you've got to support it so we
support it across every single country
where we operate and then we select from
those kids the really high performers
what what do you do if is 16 and you got
a genius on your hands you say go home
we just treat them like our own kids we
help them apply for scholarships to
Stanford and Harvard and wherever so we
have three hundred and fifty four in the
United States this year of our kids and
we've got some in China some in the UK
and so forth them and we help them along
and so it's been a great program to see
you've mentioned that entrepreneurship
is not just about making money but about
being an agent for a change there's many
people here in this audience who have
large dreams of going into the world and
being catalyst for a transformative
change what do you think we should know
and most importantly today what is your
call to action for us first of all don't
wait until you've made your billion okay
I know everyone at Stanford ends up
making a billion once they're
entrepreneurs right I mean that's why
you come to Stanford right right so look
you you're almost guaranteed to be
successful so start straightaway why do
you have to wait as you register your
company register your foundation
register your philanthropy and it's
actually good for you in our house we
actually never discuss business we
discuss the things we're doing around
philanthropy it you know with my kids
and if I it's very difficult with my
kids because they're more interested in
the philanthropy side then maybe they
during holidays they prefer go work for
their mother
very few volunteer to go and sell in one
of my shops but the reality is these
things in in today's society we have to
start straightaway there's no reason for
you to wait you've got to find something
that you've got to find a cause if you
don't find a cause you'll find that
making money is itself a quite empty
you kind of get into your course now
what is it you're interested in is it
the environment is it the climate change
is it there is something that should
capture your interest every day
and for me I can't wait at the end of my
day to escape into discussing the issues
of philanthropy that's why I'm here we
are here to discuss small holder farmers
in Africa so we make it an integral part
of what you are doing but in if there's
an even more excellent way as they say
why not just do the philanthropy and
because if if that if you if you feel
you can make a change with that going
off to run a for-profit do it that's my
council final question before we open it
up to some of our business students here
for questions what do you think are some
of the most pressing global problems
that we should be thinking about today
Wow you know we always think don't we
that we would like to hand our children
fewer problems then then we handed to us
you know our parents kind of handed over
a world with where they said well we've
achieved the Soviet Union is gone
because we live down to the Cold War and
not so sure weak handing over a great
world to you at the moment I'm sorry
about that you got a few problems that
you're gonna have to deal with because
top of mind for me is climate change
because it doesn't give us was it we
don't have a planet B somebody said we
we don't get it another shot at it
if we don't get into it now so so it's
it's up there from enough from the
African perspective it's jobs one would
argue it's global but for your
generation
it's bigger than decolonization ever was
as a challenge
we have a continent where the average
age is 19
we are 1.2 billion by some estimates
will be 4 billion by the turn of this
century in the lives of most of you if
we don't create jobs we end up with Boko
Haram and al-shabaab it's as simple as
that and they can sweep all the way down
to the south so the security Nexus is
linked to the jobs we have to create
hope you know when I think of the people
trying to cross the Mediterranean
sometimes you read reports of five
hundred drownings a week in the
Mediterranean we almost forget that they
had to cross the Sahara first to get to
the Mediterranean and yet we have a
continent with so much resources so much
capacity so it's an extraordinary charge
for us where we are still able to do
something but an even greater challenge
for our children and but it's also
global I think the stability of the
world the future of the world will to a
great extent be shaped by our response
to this so we have to pick up every tool
everything that we can to try and take
on the some of these challenges the rest
where Stanford you know them
hazing so now we'll take some questions
from the audience
I started thank you so much for being
here really appreciate it
I was just wondering on either a
personal or professional level sort of
what keeps you up at night so what do
you wake up in the morning
really concerned about thinking about
you you know I never keep up at night
[Laughter]
President Obama said to me was what
keeps you up at night I said nothing I'm
not running the world you are is it ok
suppose you woke up in the middle of
night so ok jobs how do we create
employment that that really is a
challenge to me how do we get our young
people so I am persuaded that the answer
lies in part with entrepreneurship ok if
I can't create somebody a job maybe I
can help them create their jobs
inspire them to go out and do something
but and I have an exciting job to do
which is does give me a lot of energy in
the morning we have a question right up
here ok thank you so much for this
opportunity I mean I've always dreamed
to come very close to you my name is
Brian and I'm from Zimbabwe so my
question was I understand after you
finish your your undergraduate in
Germany or somewhere in Europe I'm no
longer sure you went back to Zimbabwe to
work you know in Africa and then start
to build your ideas from the continent
what advice would you give to someone
who is graduating right now or maybe to
this specific graduating in 2020
do you think is best for us if we dream
of changing our continent through
entrepreneurship to first start wakey
and gain some skills or to go and work
maybe in past details that we think
would want to change in the future
yeah thank you that's quite multifaceted
I I think you know there's no simple
answer to this I wish I could say that
but what I can say to you
the sooner you if you have an intention
to get home and work there the sooner
you go the better it's actually very
difficult if you kind of spent five ten
years you've got a family you've got
roots and so forth that that's harder to
do I just picked up my bag and I went
home okay and you know it was it was
easy I think it would have been much
harder if it had been ten years later
but having said that I know a lot of
friends who came after they had spent
some time building up experience and so
forth and did very well but I also go as
far as to say that I'll never condemn
somebody who doesn't come okay they they
are contributor Africans living and
working in the Diaspora
are contributing as much to Africa today
as anybody who's there and I'm very
proud of what they do we can't
accommodate a lot of these guys even if
we wanted to so but they are sending
money home they are keeping people in
school the the burden they carry for
such a small group of people is
extraordinary so so I in in so that's
why I say there's no simple answer I
wish I could say there was all the above
will work out but I wouldn't send you to
a country at war there might be an issue
I had to leave Zimbabwe 18 years ago
haven't been back even for one day okay
so you know there are always issues that
one needs to take into consideration
hello
I strive hi my name is tunde I'm from
Nigeria I figured Tunde they're just
some names you know Tunde from Nigeria
Tendai from Zimbabwe I mean you you you
never get a Tendai from kenya anyways
thank you for for this opportunity kind
of picking piggybacking on your point I
feel but for about initiatives like what
Africans in the Diaspora can kind of do
to support development or goals in in
Africa more sort of enterpreneurship
rather than what you mentioned in terms
of like philanthropy or supporting folks
back home so like investments and stuff
like that because from what you said not
only do we have like people here we have
like tremendous talent the work for
tough companies and stuff like that and
there is there's a lot of conversation
around this issue today okay how can we
encourage if we call it the Diaspora
which means we include people like
LeBron James by the way he's an African
in the Diaspora in Africa we think of
all black people around the world as
part of the African Diaspora but you
know Africa is not just black people we
have a wonderful diversity on our
continent but on the serious note
there's a lot of conversation around
encouraging those who are living and
working outside Africa to invest in
creating businesses and supporting
entrepreneurship
even investing through local stock
exchanges and so for trying to mobilize
capital I'm a great supporter of that
but I haven't seen anything that I could
say to you this is the perfect solution
thank you I strive my name is Ruth I'm
from Ghana
I was wondering as a chairman of Agri
what do you think is the future of
smoulder famine in Africa and in
thinking about that how do you think
we're gonna meet food security
challenges you should listen to the
radio interview that Jeff and I did this
morning at 7 o'clock Jeff Raikes please
Jeff stand up he's the chairman of your
esteemed University but has been a
member of the agra board for many many
years and helped set it up and we spent
goodness an hour and a half and you
really got to listen to a Jeff had a say
because I was just the backup you know
I'm just I'm a city boy I'm not a farmer
but I've learnt a few things and amongst
them of course you know 70% of our food
production in Africa is done by women
small holder farmers and they are aging
it's a paradox for us we've got millions
of young people without jobs but they're
not interested in agriculture and
rightly so it it's not sustainable what
we got to do is to put in place a policy
framework that makes agriculture
modernizes the way we do agriculture
looks at agriculture as an industry
sustains the
comes of smallholder farmers increases
their incomes and and this is what we
are trying to do from the perspective of
Agri we are investing and catalyzing in
in small businesses we've created over a
hundred seed companies in Africa and
these seed companies now produce a third
of all the certified seed produced in on
the African continent
it's phenomenal in ten years they
produce enough seed to feed 15 million
people every year so we're trying to
help
30 million smallholder households
episode the the smallholder farmer is
the absolute bedrock of africa if we
there's no nation China Europe the
United States that ever got going
without sorting out their agriculture so
to the extent that so we got to put in
place the right framework from a policy
perspective and that's what we work to
try and encourage governments to do
ensure that there is sustained domestic
investment both from governments from
entrepreneurs and create a stable
environment for farmers markets ensuring
they get access to seeds and there's a
whole value chain around it so this that
there's a lot of space in agriculture hi
mr. Matthew WA I'm Elmer from Angola
here at the GSB we thought a lot about
managerial practices that were supposed
to implement to increase the likelihood
of success but those are mostly promised
on the existence of certain factors such
as the enforceability of the rule of law
or the existence of a highly qualified
labor market people that have succeeded
in developing economies in spite of
those obstacles are usually associated
with the ruling regime I think it's fair
to say that you are not one
those people but you still succeeded so
how did you do that and for those of us
that are still working on our first
billion or million or thousands how
would you what sort of advice would you
do this you know somebody asked Richard
Branson how do I become a billionaire
and he said I start buying it says how
do I become a millionaire says you know
start with the billion and buy an
airline you can you can keep but you can
we I understand where you want to go you
know it's it's it's it's it's it's one
of my challenges when I'm advising young
entrepreneurs from different African
countries because you know they're
different types of governments they're
different situations on the ground and
what I how do i advise someone from Togo
and someone in South Africa Zimbabwe
Zambia
you know because you I can't be so what
I try to do is to pre-teach principles
that will make you a success as an
entrepreneur irrespective of the
conditions and one of my mantras is to
say the entrepreneur must train like a
soldier we fight in the conditions not
the conditions because we really can't
wake up in the morning say today it's
raining I'm not fighting so so the
challenges are there but the thing is
Africa is full of entrepreneurs the this
entrepreneurship is alive and well in
Africa it is just building the support
systems to ensure that these ventures
can grow in scale so I hope that as some
of you get skills from here you can take
them home to be able to help others to
to scale
all right my name is Terry I'm from
Rhonda and I remember this may in
transform Africa you talked about house
there by the way you talked about how
data is actually to our generation is
what internet was to the 90s 80s
generation and with that I took that an
advice but I tried to look into that but
the problem is part of it data in Africa
is in the air it's not somewhere you
can't actually find data and even when
there is data it's so hard to break
through the government censorship
actually to get that data so how how
what do you think about how can you
break through that and I also have an
insight question about your program I'm
part of another program in Rhonda called
bridge Rhonda we come to the States I
didn't go back but the issue with the
program right now is it's so hard to
convince us to go back I graduate from
Stanford having an offer from Microsoft
and an offer to go back home
those two offers you can even weigh them
how do you convince your students to
actually reject the offer it's not
problem of being patriotic it's an issue
of weighing the two the two offers and
see which one is better how do you make
it more attractive to students to come
back in Africa I have a better offer for
you go and start your own business it's
better offer than Microsoft or Intel or
anybody once you decide to go down that
route none of those are good offers so
that's my challenge for you I have a
program which is fascinating which we
take young American graduates every year
this year we had 30 we offer it or not
to Africans you can't have this one you
young Americans and we send them to
Africa for three to six months and they
work for African company
they don't work for governments they
don't work it's not Peace Corps you
gotta go and you gotta work for
companies like mine and guess what they
want to come home either so there's
something going on there my friend
you gotta come afternoon my name is
Daphne aha I'm from Zimbabwe and
fortunately I'm one of your entry young
scholars I graduated from Spelman
College this this past May so I have a
background in biochemistry and I am
interested in addressing health problems
in developing countries mostly
particularly in Diagnostics because I
feel like those diseases such as malaria
HIV tuberculosis have been neglected
mostly and I'm interested in someday
owning my own biotechnology company in
Zimbabwe to address matters in Zimbabwe
because it's very very important for us
to have such facilities that allow us to
arm to try and solve our own problems
using our own resources so why should
you give what advice would you give a
young person like myself with no
background in business but interested in
making such changes to our continent to
the place that we come from wow that's
great we have a program with Morehouse
College
so Andrew Young came to me and said why
don't you have a program just for
Morehouse so that's okay so we did a
deal where it said we would send ten
students to Morehouse but I forgot that
was only meant so we ended up doing the
identical program at Spelman and that's
where the andrian program she talks
about comes
so it's always missing these amazing
young people there and this is the
future of Africa look the the most
important thing that you look the
challenges for you are there but they
are no different from any generation
anywhere else in the world
okay to the extent that you can come
home come home and we will help you and
we will get you started in the business
that you want to get into and and really
we want to say that about I mean your
country Zimbabwe which is also my
country has just gone through an
extraordinary change that the whole
world witnessed and so there's a lot of
sense of hope so I'll see you there for
Christmas next year
so I know there's still tons of
questions in the audience but you'll
have to post it to his Facebook page
because we're out of time now but I
think that we all agree that it's been
phenomenal and let's give another round
of applause
[Applause]
[Music]